so welcome everyone to the uh
d mice research conference which is um
uh not at our usual time because as
often happens towards the end of the
term we have uh
um theses and this thesis and
dissertation
proposal defenses and actual defenses
and so today
we have a dissertation proposal defense
which means that
the candidate chris clarkey will be
telling us about what he's going to do
for his dissertation and his
dissertation advisory committee is here
um quickly by way of introduction and
most people know chris
but maybe if you don't he's a phd
candidate and an
nlm trainee in the bioinformatics and
computational biomedicine
program he has a bachelor of science in
biology from american university
and worked in biotechnology development
before starting our program
and currently does research in the
genetics of cancer
and mechanisms of immunotherapy
resistance
i'd also like to call out chris for his
service to the program
in serving on the curriculum committee
and also
representing ohsu on the
program committee of the nlm trainees
meeting which
many of us will be attending next month
so the
uh usual procedure here is that he gives
a public presentation
um and then uh we open questions to the
public to everyone who's attending and
then the public is dismissed
and the dissertation advisory commit
committee may have some
additional um comments and questions for
him after we
all leave so i will turn it over to
chris
thanks for that introduction bill uh as
you mentioned i'm going to be talking
about
my approach for identifying gene
regulatory network patterns
affecting treatment outcome for a
particular class of cancer
immunotherapies
at broad level the clinical need driving
this sort of research
stems from the massive morbidity and
mortality inflicted by cancer
this category of diseases is a leading
cause of death globally
and kills 600 000 people per year in the
united states alone current treatments
are inadequate to address this clinical
challenge
and further research is needed to
resolve this gap
tumors are made up of a heterogeneous
population of cells
which poses a key hurdle to achieving
durable
treatment response a majority of
malignant cells within a tumor
may be sensitive to a chosen therapy but
the treatment will act as a darwinian
selective pressure
selecting for a small resistant
subpopulation of cells
that expand and drive disease recurrence
in the past decade we have witnessed the
development of a range of technologies
that can profile various molecular
processes in a tissue sample at the
single cell level of resolution
this is particularly useful when we're
trying to understand
and study the tumor heterogeneity that
drives treatment resistance
single cell rna sequencing is a
technology of particular interest
because it allows researchers to obtain
a gene expression profile
for each of thousands of cells within a
sample
we can then study numerous cell types
and cell states that may be present
one limitation to consider when using
these single cell assays is sparsity
you know while we can get a single cell
level of resolution
some signal will be lost due to
biological and technical sources of
dropout
and we will not get an accurate
quantification of every gene in every
cell
when studying biological systems the
classical approach is to consider one
gene at a time and to determine its
function
or disease relevance however it has
become clear
that in order to reach a deeper level of
understanding
we need to take a more holistic system
level view
we can consider something like signal
transduction pathways consisting of
various
protein-protein interactions as being
part of this system level view
but my research really focuses on the
gene regulatory networks
that control the expression of genes
within a cell
if we think of a gene which may code for
a transcription factor
that transcription factor may then you
know interact with different regions in
the genome in a way that
activates or represses the expression of
other genes
some of these other genes may be
transcription factors in the code for
transcription factors themselves
which then have other downstream targets
and in this way we have
these you know interlinked systems of
regulation of gene expression
now these networks are typically very
carefully controlled but they can become
dysregulated in cancer
and it's important to understand how
these grns become dysregulated to fully
understand
mechanisms of treatment resistance
one convenient side effect of taking a
gene regulatory network level approach
is that it helps to address this
sparsity limitation of single cell data
that i mentioned
since we are focused on sets of genes
that are co-regulated
rather than individual genes
we can think of a so-called regulon
which consists of
a transcription factor and its direct
downstream targets
as sort of the basic functional unit of
a gene regulatory network
these so-called regulons can be inferred
with various computational approaches
that i will
discuss in more detail
the treatments that i'm interested in
fall
into a category known as cancer
immunotherapies
now the the question that really drives
the development
of this class of therapies is you know
can we
somehow harness or modulate the
patient's own immune system
in order to treat cancer part of the
appeal of this
is specificity since a lot of existing
approaches to cancer
you know are damaging to healthy tissue
which leads to
side effects and are very hard on the
patient so the ability
to target malignant cells while leaving
healthy cells intact
is very appealing and as you can see in
this uh
in this image on the left here we have a
uh in green we have a cytotoxic t
cell that is in the process of
destroying a malignant cell
one promising class of cancer
immunotherapies that i'm going to focus
in on a little bit here
is known as immune checkpoint inhibition
in healthy patients the immune system
can often recognize and destroy
cells that are dysregulated and may
develop into a tumor
however certain inhibitory signaling
pathways known as immune checkpoints
can down regulate or deactivate this
psychotoxic immune activity
one particular immune checkpoint
consists of the proteins pd1 and pl1
which we can see in the figure
tumors can take advantage of this type
of inhibitory signaling in order to
evade destruction by the immune system
in the past decade or so researchers
have
developed drugs to interfere with the
signaling
of these inhibitory pathways they've
developed
monoclonal antibodies known as immune
checkpoint inhibitors
that bind to these immune checkpoint
proteins and interfere with their
inhibitory signaling
and in this way they can reinitiate the
immune
response against the tumor and cause it
to recognize these
malignant cells once again
inhibitors of pd1 pdl1 and ctla4
have become fda approved for
uh several different cancer types and
who generated particular interest in
recent years
now these drugs are highly successful in
a subset of patients which is
uh you know part part of what has
generated this interest they can
lead to years of disease-free survival
in patients with um with otherwise
untreatable
you know late-stage metastatic disease
who have no other viable options among
existing therapies however that being
said
most patients do not respond and
what's more the mechanisms by which some
patients respond
and others don't is not fully understood
and we can't predict with high accuracy
out of time
who's going to respond and who will not
since the response to these therapies is
based on an interaction between multiple
cell types
primarily the malignant cells and the t
cells we need to understand both tumor
intrinsic
and tumor extrinsic factors that may be
involved in treatment response and
resistance
so we need to understand the malignant
cell populations that may be
capable of driving resistance to these
treatments we need to understand
t cell states that affect treatment
outcome
and importantly particularly for my
first aim we need to understand the
influence of
other immune cell types in the tumor
microenvironment
i now want to take a minute to mention
a cellular process that has caught the
attention of researchers
in recent years known as t cell
exhaustion
if you look at the top part of this
diagram kind of starting over on the
left here
we can see the progression of c t cell
states in the case of a normal infection
so when a naive t cell encounters its
specific target it becomes activated
into an effector t cell
which can then work to clear the
infection
a subset of these activated t cells will
be retained as memory
t cells ready to be quickly reactivated
upon
a second exposure to their target
now if we consider the bottom part of
the diagram we can observe a different
process that occurs when t
cells are consistently exposed to
their target over a long period of time
without eliminating it
this could be due to chronic infections
such as hepatitis c
or a tumor that can't be fully
eliminated by the immune system
chronic stimulation can drive t cells
through a series of
cell states uh known as exhausted and
in these exhausted t cells they have um
as you can see on the top right they
have reduced effector function
uh it's not absent but it's uh it's much
less
they exhibit they express a variety of
these immune checkpoint proteins that i
that i described previously and they
have uh
kind of distinct altered gene expression
and chromatin accessibility profiles
while this research is still at an early
stage and this is just a model of our
current understanding
it appears that there are a series of
cell states that exist
along a continuum of t cell exhaustion
these range from progenitor exhausted t
cells
that have stem cellic properties to
more terminally exhausted t cells
whether immune checkpoint blockade
therapy
can reverse exhaustion in some cells or
if it causes progenitor cells to
differentiate
and kind of temporarily have more
effector function is not really clear
however there is some evidence to
support that
patients that have a greater uh
proportion of progenitor exhausted t
cells to terminally exhaust it uh do
show better response but as i mentioned
this is
this is all just kind of a model of a
recent understanding that's come in the
past couple years
and more work is needed to
really sharpen this understanding in the
context of human tumors
there has been some work that's been
done
using single cell rna sequencing and
other methods
in order to characterize uh both the
tumor
extrinsic and tumor intrinsic factors
that drive
treatment resistant resist the the tumor
extrinsic factors
such as t cell exhaustion and the tumor
micro environment
uh you know there has been some work to
to characterize t cell exhaustion
but you know there are a few limitations
to the work that's been done
to start most of the work that's been
done to characterize this has been done
on a particular viral infection known as
lcmv so mice that are chronically
infected
and you know many cancer immunologists
have stated that
these findings may or may not generalize
to the context of human tumors and
it's um it's really it's important at
this point to kind of
move beyond that model in order to
determine what's actually going on in
the context of human tumors
the existing approaches have been uh for
the most part overly gene centric rather
than kind of taking a
holistic system level view
they've been mostly focused on the t
cells themselves rather than
malignant cell populations and other
immune cell types
so in order to address these uh these
limitations these shortcomings
we need a better characterization of t
cell exhaustion
specifically in the context of human
tumors
we need a system level understanding of
the gene regulation patterns
that are involved we need a comparison
to be able to compare and contrast
between what's going on in the case of
human tumors
and human chronic infections so we can
determine
what results generalize from the um
from the case of human tumor from the
from the viral case to the to the tumor
case
and which don't and then importantly
particularly for my first
specific game we need a better
understanding of what contributors
in the tumor immune micro environment
could potentially be driving this t cell
exhaustion process i will
address each of these with an approach
as for the
[Music]
as for the tumor intrinsic properties of
the malignant cells themselves
that are associated with driving
response or resistance to these drugs
you know we can think about this first
in kind of the
simplified case analogous to a targeted
therapy where we have
you know many cells that are sensitive
in a subpopulation that are resistant
and we apply the drug the resistant
population is selected for
and then expands however in the case of
immunotherapies it's
potentially a little bit different than
this because as i mentioned before
the mechanism of response is based on an
interaction between
multiple cell types not just whether or
not the cancer cells themselves
are responsive so we could actually have
cases where
there's activity in a subpopulation of
malignant cells
that actually prevents the destruction
of
or reduces the destruction of any of the
the malignant cells within a tumor
and there's been some work using single
cell rna sequencing that's shown
some expression activity that causes a
reduction
of infiltration of t cells into the
tumor um you know based on this
tumor intrinsic signaling uh however
this is you know really just kind of
preliminary work and
and a much greater understanding of what
tumor intrinsic activity can actually
contribute to
uh immune checkpoint blockade resistance
is needed at this point
so in order to address kind of
these gaps in our current understanding
that i've described up to this point
it kind of brings us to two questions so
the first question
is you know what activity in particular
immune cell types in the tumor micro
environment
could be helping to drive this t-cell
exhaustion process
so our goal is to identify these these
contributors
hypothesis here is that i can use sample
level ordering
based on the uh trajectory of cd8t cells
in order to identify these
microenvironment
drivers of exhaustion and i'm going to
talk about what i mean by that
in in much greater detail
the second aim i propose you know while
the first name is more focused on immune
cell types
the second aim is uh focused on the
tumor intrinsic
factors so that the activity in the
malignant cells the question here
is you know can we identify
what activity is present uh prior to
therapy
that contributes to resistance but then
also how this
how this expression shifts and
potentially changes over the course of
treatment
particularly in patients who are
resistant so we want to identify clonal
evolution
and gene regulatory network changes
in particularly in resistant patients
and the hypothesis here is that i can
use inferred copy number variation
to track subclonal populations of cancer
cells longitudinally
across icf treatment and again i'm gonna
explain
you know exactly what i mean by that in
greater detail
the first aim this is just an overview
i'm gonna walk through each of these
uh each of these steps the in the first
name we're going to be identifying
tumor immune microenvironment drivers of
t-cell exhaustion
by walking through a series of steps
to start i'm going to take single cell
rna sequencing data
from samples from patients
with various skin cancer tumors that
have not yet been treated with
immune checkpoint inhibitors i'm also
going to
as an addition to this i'm going to be
taking
immune cells from some patients who have
a chronic viral infection with hiv
the the main part of the analysis
focuses on this tumor sample data
first i'm going to use a cell cluster
annotation
process in order to identify various
cell types and cell states
so as we can see on the right
the the malignant cells are going to
tend to
group together um if we were to break
down these clusters and malignant cells
the cells from each sample they would
kind of
cluster out by tumor of origin based on
their
intertumor heterogeneity and their
specific mutation profiles
however when we look at the immune cell
types
they tend to group together based on
their expression profiles
into their specific cell types and even
states within cell types
with you know each cell type consisting
of
cells from a variety of samples so they
um
so in this way we're kind of able to
analyze them all altogether which is
nice
so based on using known gene expression
markers
that identify these cell types i'm going
to select out the cd8t cells
from each sample
i will then take these cda t cells and
perform
a trajectory inference process using
one of several established algorithms
this t-cell
this this trajectory inference process
uses the gene expression profiles of
cells
to kind of put them into this
pseudo-temporal ordering
of you know a continuum of shifting cell
states here
so um one trajectory inference algorithm
that
has has shown some success is known as
paga so this is kind of a figure
but this is there are other like monocle
three there are other leading methods
that
are based on kind of this similar idea
where we have
a k nearest neighbors graph here where
cells that have broadly similar
expression profiles
will you know be linked as
close neighbors here and then we have
these different clusters of
of cell states shifting from one to the
next along this continuum
that gives us this um this
pseudo-temporal ordering
you know of this trajectory of cells so
in this way i'm going to be using
um you know this algorithm in order to
put these t cells in order you know we
might expect to get some naive t cells
effector t cells
and then ideally
i'm hoping to see you know a series of
progressively more exhausted t-cell
states
and i won't know exactly what sort of
lineage topology to expect until i
actually run the algorithm
whether it's going to be you know an
actual continuum with the intermediate
state sampled or if i have
you know more discrete cell states
but really the the point of this here
if i was just interested in the
expression of
the cda t cells themselves along this
trajectory i could kind of just stop
here but since since i'm interested
in uh identifying other
activity and other immune cell types i
kind of have to take it up to the sample
level
so at this point i'm going to use that
cellular level ordering of
of the cda t cells to perform an
ordering at the
the sample level so just to kind of take
a simple case here
if we imagine the exhausted t cells from
a particular sample
will be distributed somewhere along this
this exhaustion trajectory and they're
not going to be
distributed in exactly the same place
for each sample so in this way we can
place the cells in order you know using
various methods that i can discuss if we
have time
to place these samples in order based on
the overall degree of t cell exhaustion
in that sample
now once we have this information just a
step away from
specifically the cda t cells for a
minute i'm going to be performing gene
regulatory network inference
on a variety of immune cell types
in order to do this i'm going to be
using another several algorithms
one such algorithm known as scenic the
way it works is
uh it looks at transcription factors and
then it looks at other genes that are
highly
co-expressed with that transcription
factor and that sort of gives you a
first pass of what might be regulated by
that transcription factor
that is then further
enriched based on the the presence of
transcription factor binding motifs in
these potential
directly regulated targets then at that
point we can
get a tren these these regulons i
discussed
uh with the transcription factor and
downstream targets and we can quantify
the degree of activity
of that sort of uh gene regulatory
network
sub network at a at a higher level so
at this point i'm going to i'm going to
perform gene regulatory network
inference to identify these immune cell
type specific regulons and then
once i have this information paired with
this
sample level exhaustion ordering that i
discussed in the last step
we're going to put the two together so
just to take the simple case i'm going
to be looking for an association
between immune cell type specific
regulons
and this sample level exhaustion
ordering
to take to take the simple case of a
monotonic
relationship we can just use kind of a
rank-based non-parametric
correlation to look for aguilon activity
that
kind of tracks with this exhaustion
in the case of non-monotonic
relationships
there are other statistical frameworks
that i can use to identify
groups of regulons that are active
particular points in this
t cell exhaustion trajectory
at this point once i've identified
gene regulatory subunits these regulons
that are associated with t cell
exhaustion in the tumor immune micro
environment
i can then start to put the pieces
together and analyze this from
a more system level so at this point
if i identify a transcription factor
that has a set of downstream targets
one of those downstream targets may code
for or maybe a transcription factor
that has its own set of downstream
targets and in this way we can start to
establish this uh this hierarchy of
these regulatory relationships
and then once once this has been done
i can perform a gene regulatory network
analysis to look for
you know things like the degree of flow
through particular
nodes in the network and you know if we
have
an activity change in a particular
transcription factor
you know what what percent of the
variance of that is being explained by
the activity of you know some upstream
regulator and we can start to get this
more
uh holistic picture of actually what's
going on
in this regulated system
now i mentioned briefly that i'm going
to be including some data from
chronically infected patients along with
this in the trajectory
and this is just as an addition to the
same
this is going to allow me to compare and
see what
t cell exhaustion expression activity
in this in these cdat cells is shared
between
the chronic infection case and the tumor
case and what is tumor specific
and the important thing is here is that
this will help us
start to be able to figure out what
results from the chronic infection case
actually generalized to the human tumor
case and which do not
just to recap here i'm going to start
with this single cell data
i'm going to use cell cluster annotation
to select that the cdat cells
i'm going to perform trajectory
inference to get a pseudo-temporal
ordering
of these cdat cells that are
progressively more exhausted
i'm going to use that cellular level
ordering to get a sample level ordering
in order to rank the samples based on
their overall
degree of cell exhaustion and then look
for
these gene regulatory sub network
modules that uh that are associated with
this exhaustion ordering and then i can
perform the system level
gene regulatory network analysis
upon completion of this aim i expect to
have found several things i expect to
have identified
some of these immune cell type specific
regulons that are associated with t cell
exhaustion
i expect to potentially have identified
some of these gene regulatory network
relationships
and to have a greater understanding of
this comparison of exhaustion between
tumors
and the case of chronic infection
some limitations to this approach are
the
uncertainty inherent to the
computational inference of these gene
regulatory networks
uh the fact that this exhaustion process
still is not fully understood so there's
um no underlying ground truth here
although we have some
um have been some understanding from the
literature to guide us here
and as with any uh correlation based
you know computational analysis there's
the potential for confounding factors
here although i will be taking
um some steps to help mitigate that
and with that i want to uh kind of shift
gears to my second specific aim here
which focuses on tumor intrinsic factors
so expression activity in the malignant
cells themselves
that is associated with resistance to
immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy
this is uh sort of an overview here so
i'm going to be walking through a series
of steps
and then again i'll recap
to start i'm going to be taking single
cell rna sequencing data
from some skin cancer tumors
and here we have data from responders
and non-responders to therapy
and also paired data from paired samples
uh pre and post treatment so this allows
for a
longitudinal analysis where we can see
change over time
the central part of this aim
is really based on the computational
inference
of copy number variation which allows us
to identify
genetically distinct subclones that can
then be tracked
longitudinally throughout treatment so
just for a minute here if we think about
a subpopulation of cells you know
based on their expression before
treatment you know how do we know
uh which cells post-treatment you know
these cells correspond to how do we kind
of do this
a one-to-one mapping to actually be able
to track cells
longitudinally across therapy and one
way to do this is to actually explicitly
have genotype information
but since we're working with just single
cell
expression profiling here
this is why i'm adding in this uh you
know this use of computational inference
of
copy number variation so there's an
algorithm known as honey badger which
basically the way this works is it takes
two pieces of information as input
in order to predict if large stretches
of chromosomes
are amplified deleted or if they are
kind of just
left intact or copy number neutral and
the way it does this
is um it uses
right so two pieces of information the
first information is a gene expression
so is the abundance of expression um you
know increased along this
section of the genome uh or is it
reduced or absent which could indicate
deletion
and then in addition to that uh we also
use
this uh this allele balance information
for transcribed snips so if we think
about
um just heterozygous sections of the
genome
where we have different alleles and
different snips present
then when genes are transcribed these
differences show up in the mrna
transcripts
and then in our our sequencing reads
so in this way we would expect you know
to see something around
um 50 50 um allele balance
in normal heterozygous regions but if we
see something more like
um you know 80 percent um one allele and
then 20
that could indicate that one is
amplified or if we have
a large region where um
you know it's just not heterozygous and
there's one missing this could indicate
some sort of deletion or loss of
heterozygosity so in this way
we can use this this computational
method to
infer copy number variation that then
allows us to
define these
genomically distinct subpopulations of
cells within a tumor
which then allows us to track
longitudinally so
you know this population prior to
treatment corresponds to
another subpopulation following
treatment
i first just want to direct your
attention to this figure on the right
here so this this comes from a paper
a couple years ago that looked at clonal
evolution
and transcriptional reprogramming in the
case of chemotherapy
and the nice thing here is that they had
single cell expression
and single cell genotype information and
they were able to
identify that there were these multiple
genetically distinct subpopulations of
cells prior to treatment most were
resistant and were just eliminated by
the therapy
but there was this subpopulation that
was resistant and was
you know selected for an expanded
following treatment
however the important thing is here in
addition to just discovering this colon
evolution they also saw transcriptional
reprogramming
so the expression profiles of these
cells post-treatment didn't resemble
the expression of any of the cells
pre-treatment showing that there were
there was this genetically distinct
subpopulation that was capable of
resistance but then its expression
profile
shifted in response to therapy
so kind of taking a conceptually similar
approach to the case of immunotherapies
we're going to be looking for um you
know
first in the case of patients who
respond we might expect to see clonal
extinction
so some populations of malignant cells
that are
reduced in frequency or eliminated over
the course of
treatment however in patients who are
resistant we would expect to see
um either the kind of clonal persistence
or clonal expansion
following treatment which we which we
can identify
using this uh inferred copy number is a
link between the two
once that's been performed focusing
primarily on the patients who do not
respond to therapy
and perform this gene regulatory network
inference that i mentioned in the first
step
to look for these regulons in
pre and post treatment malignant cells
and start to quantify their change in
activity
so you know for example do we see a
subpopulation of malignant cells
expressing radion
that is very much upregulated or down
regulated
longitudinally across therapy during
resistance
in addition to this we can look at
regulatory reprogramming
so you know while a particular regulon
might be
defined by a transcription factor and
have a certain set of targets prior to
therapy
the same transcription factor may have a
mostly overlapping but slightly
different set of direct targets after
therapy
due to things like different levels of
chromatin accessibility
and other things so we can see this
actual um
rewiring of the regulatory relationships
of the
gene regulatory network here
after completing this step similarly to
aim 1
i can reconstruct the gene regulatory
network hierarchy here
to look at some of these regulatory
relationships
at a whole system level and i can
analyze these expression contexts or
these expression changes in the context
of the gene regulatory network you know
so again we can
picture a particular transcription
factor you know whose activity changes
longitudinally
across treatment during resistance but
then potentially that's being
uh influenced by one or more um
upstream regulators of that and we can
start to see that um
we can start to see that process
unfold and you know this is this has
been shown to be
this type of analysis has been shown to
be useful
where you know we might have multiple
targets of
immune checkpoint inhibition that are
actually both controlled by the same
upstream regulator
so this allows us to identify that sort
of thing
just to recap here
i'm going to start with single cell rna
sequencing data from
responders and non-responders with this
paired pre and post
i'm going to use inferred copy number to
identify these subclonal populations and
then track them longitudinally
across treatment i will then perform a
clonal evolution analysis
and look for transcriptional and
regulatory reprogramming
that occurs particularly in the case of
treatment resistance
and then i will perform a gene
regulatory network analysis and
be able to analyze this system as a
whole
upon the completion of this aim i expect
to have identified
several things i expect opening up these
patterns
of clonal evolution
various patterns of transcriptional and
regulatory reprogramming associated with
treatment resistance
and some of the gene regulatory network
relationships
between these transcription factors
some limitations of this approach
include
you know this is uncertainty uh inherent
to the the computational inference steps
uh as well as a limited sample size
on completion of uh these these two
specific games i expect to have
contributed to the field and helped fill
some of these gaps
in several ways
i will with my first name have
identified immune cell type specific
regulons that are associated with this t
cell exhaustion process
and then with my second aim identify
changes in
malignant cell gene regulatory network
activity
across this uh ici resistance process
will have created two computational
pipelines that can be applied to
novel biological questions
and then using these pipelines i will be
able to enable
further um analysis so these can be
applied
the pipeline from the first name can be
used for the discovery of cell
extrinsic contributors to cell state
change
and the pipeline from the second name
can then be used for longitudinal
tracking
of cell subpopulations using expression
data alone
where genotype information is not
available
and then to just take a more kind of
long-term
translational view and think about
some of the more clinically relevant
work that
this this research could support and
enable
uh we can think about the future
potential for
targeting uh the tumor immune micro
environment in some way to
improve the response rates to immune
checkpoint
inhibition therapy and additionally kind
of in the case of the tumor intrinsic
factors
we can think about the potential for
targeting tumor intrinsic programs
driving resistance and
in this way um by modulating the
activity of either the malignant cells
or the tumor
microenvironment you know potentially we
can take
this uh this class of therapies that is
highly successful just in a small subset
of patients
and to um to really expand the number of
patients that uh that have the potential
to benefit
from these types of therapies
in order to complete this work i plan to
uh you know get started this summer on
data processing
and various uh normalization steps
working with the data
i will then move into the early part of
the analysis performing
some inference steps and start building
these computational pipelines
we'll then get to a point where i'll
start to get some results and i can
analyze them and write them up into into
some manuscripts you know which will
lead me to
ultimately the point where i am ready to
defend my dissertation
at this point uh i would like to thank
my advisor guam
wu who has you know worked with me to to
help develop this research proposal
uh as well as the rest of my committee
uh shannon mcqueeney
amy moran and andrew adey who have um
who have worked with me to to help uh
you know put together this proposal
i'd like to thank the the d mice all the
students and fellows
um you know who have really given me a
lot of useful feedback and support
throughout this process
uh as always the demise faculty and
staff who are
um you know who are really helpful as
well as a
variety of other people who have uh you
know given me useful feedback as i've
as i've developed this research approach
and i'd like to just acknowledge my
funding from
the national library of medicine grant
and with that
i would like to open it up for some
questions
great thanks for your presentation
um people can either
unmute and ask questions or
type into the chat
any questions for chris
hey chris a great talk um i had a
question and i probably just missed it
can you explain
what a pseudo temporal
um yeah some people ordering sure yeah
yeah i i was kind of using two different
terms there which
might have made it unnecessarily
complicated but basically the idea of
these trajectory inference algorithms
is that um you know if we have a series
of cell states that
that may be similar but they're kind of
transitioning from one to the next
um the the idea is that uh cells that
have
uh you know very similar expression
profiles are kind of
maybe in the same or a similar cell
state and then
we can kind of use uh you know this
transition from one cell state to the
next we can infer this
uh computationally kind of based on this
this k nearest neighbors graph
type approach and in this way we can see
you know maybe we have naive t cells
that then transition to effector t
cells that then transition to some other
cell type so we can start to see
um you know we can perform computational
inference
using expression data as input to start
to kind of see how these cell states uh
progress from one to the next so that's
kind of broadly speaking
what these trajectory inference
algorithms do and then
pseudo temporal ordering is kind of just
a
jargon term of art that describes kind
of the
uh this sort of path or trajectory that
is that is inferred by these algorithms
okay cool thank you
hey chris it's jennifer
um great presentation um here i can turn
my video on
um so you said that you are for your
second aim you're inferring
um the copy number based on
gene expression and uh and
allele expression but you also
said that like after treatment
the gene expression of a particular
population can change right
um right so sorry sorry about mr but did
you
um talk about how you're doing that
mapping
of you know if you're if you're if
you're basing the
copy number on gene expression and then
gene expression changes potentially
um how are you kind of reconciling that
yeah that's a great question uh let me
just go to the side of your second
right so we want to be able to track
kind of from one
um population to the other so
uh right so the the approach is based on
this uh
computational inference of number
variation like you said
and um you know
the the idea is that uh the expression
profiles
of um of these subclones will show
these uh you know genomic alterations in
ways that can actually be
uh be detected to to identify these
subpopulations of cells
but that you know we might see uh you
know small changes
uh in the activity of these gene
regulatory networks that can then be
identified
so the thing here is these these
profiles
um kind of of the inferred copy number
they don't have to be exactly identical
for this to work
um you know if we think about this kind
of like in a um
like a phylogenetic tree where we have
you know these multiple subclonal
populations
um even if uh you know two
subpopulations are
um are a little bit different or you
know like you said that
the the expression changes that we're
trying to detect with the analysis
you know i guess really the heart of
your question is you know couldn't that
uh cause you to infer that you know
maybe they're not actually in the same
sub-clone population which
um you know could cause a problem but as
long as they
are as long as they are similar enough
we can still kind of classify them as
being in the same
subclonal population and just kind of in
addition to that
um you know some some treatments like
you know something like a chemotherapy
you would expect it to
induce additional mutations um
you know which uh you know could cause
differences before and after
but that's not really a concern here uh
for two reasons you know one of which is
because
um you know there's evidence to suggest
that uh immunotherapies
um actually don't really induce you know
many or any
um you know genetic uh alterations
uh through the course of treatment but
then uh
kind of just to tie that back to your
original point
um even if there is some difference in
either the actual copy number variation
or our inference of the copy number
variation based on the expression
as long as the um the overall
inferred copy number profile is broadly
similar enough to
to allow us to kind of identify these
subpopulations of cells as more similar
to each other than
um you know than other malignant cell
subpopulations then
then this should still work uh so this
is a really great question thanks
yeah that makes sense nice job chris
this is great thanks
chris i'm going to follow up on that
question just to ask you
can you think of gene regulatory
networks that you may
propose to regulate some of the
subclone outgrowth if it's not through
copy number robust copy number changes
due to a carcinogenic or some sort of
environmental stress like chemo
can you think of what sort of gene
regulatory networks you may expect to
see
under immunological pressure
yeah um i just want to make sure i'm
understand you're
understanding your questions so um are
you really getting at the link
between the copy number changes
themselves and the activity of the gene
regulatory network or
are you asking about like specific like
biologically what specific uh
yeah types of processes might be
involved in this
biologically because i don't think
you're going to see yeah the biological
processes and gene regulatory
networks that you think would be
changing right i mean at this point um
you know it'll be kind of a guess i
could uh i could base that on
you know what i've seen in in past
research you know like for example
um you know there's there's some data in
uh you know single cell data of
uh you know analysis of melanoma that
shows these uh kind of t cell exclusion
programs where
you know there's expression in malignant
cell subpopulations that leads to
less infiltration of
of t cells and other immune cells into
the tumor microenvironment
you know which could could make the
tumor as a whole less responsive to
immunotherapy
if i were to kind of just kind of
uh you know think about what other
types of things we could discover here i
mean this could be
anything that affects the
the presence or absence of immune cells
in
the tumor immune micro environment the
degree of inflammation
you know inhibitory signaling um
you know the things that allow the you
know tumor proliferation
it could really be be a variety of
different things and um
uh yeah so it's at a certain point i'm
gonna have to
uh you know see what i find and then and
then see if that
makes sense in the context of uh you
know of of what is known
um but yeah it'll be interesting to see
what i find there
any other questions for chris
hey okay oh go so go ahead thank you
ben yeah chris uh i really appreciate
your explanatory
uh skills that really um i get a lot out
of your presentation
um immune cancer immunotherapy uh
has some pretty big problems with uh
also
uh sort of collateral damage
even if it's not as uh all comers as
chemotherapy right so
so uh the endocrine system is really
famous for
for getting hit accidentally or a
collateral for
immunotherapy so to tie that concern
into this
is there some way that you
might be considering either now or in
the future
uh the adaptive
uh functions of of t cell exhaustion in
a way that
you know it might be positive or there
might be problems if you
reverse those exhaustion processes
uh and so i just want to ask that broad
question does that factor into how
you're looking at this
yeah absolutely that's that's such a
great point and it's something that i've
i've thought about a lot and i
you know just it was a little bit about
out of scope to go into it in the main
talk but
you know i'd be happy to talk about it
um i'm trying to
figure out which slide yeah actually i'm
gonna go back to
um you know so we have these immune
checkpoints and um you know if we think
about this from an evolutionary
perspective
these aren't just there for no reason
you know it's uh you know there's this
there's this balance
between um you know if we have an immune
system that
you know a patient with an immune system
that's that's not working enough then
potentially that person is going to be
at greater risk for um you know
disease from different pathogens and and
also potentially cancer from less immune
surveillance
um but then if we kind of just you know
it's not the immune system isn't a
pure positive if we just endlessly ramp
it up you know we get we get
autoimmunity which can be
can be just as devastating and um so
it's
you know it's it's proposed you know
pretty plausibly i think that these
immune checkpoints evolved um as a
as a kind of a prevention of you know
excess
immune activity and excess um you know
cellular damage and um
you know so this t cell exhaustion
process you know many people have
proposed that
um you know if if these t cells are just
being consistently stimulated and
they're you know they have this
consistent effector activity
then you know you mentioned collateral
damage it's just you know it's too much
uh cytotoxicity to the surrounding
healthy tissue
um and so that you know this might be an
evolved way to kind of strike a balance
between the two
and then to just pull it back to um kind
of the clinical point where you really
started
you know yes there is um you know
cytokine release syndrome and you know
many
of these patients who get immunotherapy
i think in in
often in patients who uh do show a
response too um
you get these um these uh you know
cytokine release events and you get this
autoimmunity which is um
you know that in and of itself can be a
huge problem so kind of
trying to figure out um you know
why some patients experience certain
potentially very harmful side effects
from these therapies and kind of
how to either predict those or mitigate
those is um
is really a whole um a whole area of
research unto itself that you know will
be would be really interesting to
to dive into but that's i'm you know i
always appreciate when you bring in the
uh the clinical perspective and it's
it's important to think about
um you know not just the these aren't a
silver bullet not just the potential
benefits of an approach but the way
you know that they could actually um
that they could actually harm the
patient so it's a it's a really
great point thanks thanks chris
great work
chris i don't know if i should save all
my questions and comments until we meet
but i just want to highlight ben's point
here because that might be a really
interesting data set for you to look at
if it's available down the road is our
i know we're tracking um these immune
related adverse events in these patients
uh as you know as immunotherapists we
we expect them and um so
so we're recording them and we're
studying them but it might be very
interesting to look
in the data sets in which
there is you know rashes
patients developing all these rashes and
are they sequencing and doing single
cell sequencing
on the t cells in the non-tumor tissue
that would provide insight in the
mechanisms of reactivation
right because those are those were cells
that were
not causing pathology until until
checkpoint blockade was
introduced and now they're pathogenic
and so their function has been released
and so overlaying those data sets
after you do your initial analysis might
be really powerful
and provide a unique insight into
mechanisms of
exhaustion and activation
yeah that's that's definitely something
i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to think about and and
just to tie you know what you said back
to ben's point
uh you know where you said these are
these are cells i think you said these
are cells that were not originally
causing any pathology um until this
change was made
um you know which that kind of
reinforces this uh this evolutionary
perspective that
you know this signaling that we're
interrupting with uh this the signal
that we're interfering with
um it's not there for no reason you know
there
there was a purpose to it and you know
by by interfering with it we need to be
cognizant of um
you know kind of the risks and knock-on
effects that can be involved with that
so that's um yeah that's interesting i'm
gonna have to think some more about that
good okay well it sounds like there's
actually more interesting uh discussion
and so maybe um
we'll we'll let uh chris and his uh
committee uh carry it on there
um so thank you everyone for attending
today
and um as you saw from chris's timeline
he'll be back at some point in the
future to defend his dissertation
so see everyone later bye-bye thank you